[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous bienvenue sur
public sénat ravi de vous retrouver pour
une nouvelle semaine dalons plus loin
nous sommes ensemble en direct pendant
deux heures on va donc prendre le temps
d'analyser de questionner toute
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
on va d'abord le fer avec notre invité
du jour c'est un aiguillon bienvenu
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
êtes sina trice union centriste de la
vendée vous réagirez notamment à cette
proposition loi de bruno retailleau pour
interdire les listes communautariste aux
municipales durant ces deux heures nous
irons comme tous les jours en salle des
conférences pour recueillir les
réactions d'autres sénateurs et
sénatrices et ce sera avec fanny conquis
aujourd'hui à tout à leur famille allons
plus loin c'est aussi le club
trois intervenants qui ont des choses à
vous dire aujourd'hui dans le club jean
masse y est bienvenu fondateur but
d'akrour d'acropolis pardon et gens vous
allez faire du fact checking aujourd'hui
et oui absolument on va parler de cette
fameuse proposition de bruno retailleau
d'interdire les listes communautariste
aux élections à suivre dans le club
également marie pierre bourgeois marie
bien vous marie pierre bienvenu nous
sommes avec vous sur la commission d'
enquête sénatoriale autour de l'incendié
de lubrizol m'a pas aidé un pdg
américain qui a reçu demain dans la
maison et les très attendus ils disaient
mari parce qu'il ya vraiment une marie
c'est marie brémaud bienvenus marie vous
êtes notre spécialiste europe et j'ai
envie de dire on va parler du bric site
rio où on va aller un peu plus loin dans
l'absurdité ce soir
allons plus loin dans l'absurdité c'est
un beau programme dans une demi-heure
sénat en clair nos vies rebond sur le
mouvement à la sncf du week end il est
parti du droit de retrait est lié à des
problèmes de sécurité mais beaucoup
parlent d'un avant-goût du mouvement
social contre les retraites grèves sncf
ce n'est qu'un début
hashtag alp elle si vous avez envie de
réagir sur twitter avant cela cette
proposition de loi du patron des
sénateurs a l'air donc il veut faire
interdire les listes communautariste aux
municipales principales cibles l'union
des démocrates musulmans
votre position dans un instant animé
lyon d'abord les détails avec béatrice
un an
il souhaite déposer une proposition de
loi pour interdire les listes
communautariste aux élections bruno
retailleau l'a annoncé dans le journal
du dimanche
nous proposons d'interdire tout
financement public d'un mouvement
communautariste qui ne respecteraient
pas les principes de souveraineté
nationale et de laïcité pour la droite
c'est liste existe déjà notamment
seine-saint-denis lors du des élections
passées on a vu effectivement fleurir sa
tombe de liste ou deux candidats qui
manifestement n'a vait pas en partage
les valeurs de la république la question
sur ce sujet ça va être la qualification
juridique de ces listes ou ses candidats
et là c'est d'une extrême difficulté et
et même lorsque nous l'aurions qualifier
je pense que certains seront
suffisamment habile pour contourner le
cadre juridique nous aurons que nous
aurons plus instaurer pour l'heure les
conseillers municipaux ne sont pas
soumis à une obligation de neutralité
religieuse
parmi les partis existants l'union des
démocrates musulmans français ne se sent
pas visé et réaffirme son caractère laïc
où seul un parti laïc et qui oeuvre pour
la concorde nationale pour qu'une partie
de la population ne soit pas en
permanence stigmatiser mais c'est dans
une optique réellement de concorde
nationale et de citoyenneté généralisée
donc nous sommes en fait une bonne
nouvelle pour la démocratie puisque nous
allons permettre à tous les français de
s'exprimer et en partie ceux qui sont
justement actuellement stigmatisé pour
des questions de bouts de tissus l'union
des démocrates musulmans français a
obtenu 0 13% des voix lors des élections
européennes et plus de 10% dans 50
bureaux de vote du pays pour compte
un tel texte notez moi je ne veux pas
qu'on soit amené contourner personnages
publics à prendre position
systématiquement pour des positions les
plus radicales
alors que le sujet est extrêmement
complexe moi je souhaiterais c'est la
question qui se pose aujourd'hui qu'on
traite la question du communautarisme et
la radicalité
ce qui n'est pas du tout la place des
musulmans
dans notre société c'est autre chose et
ce qui doit préoccuper le gouvernement
aujourd'hui c'est la lutte contre la
radicalisation et donc je trouve que de
circonscrire le débat autour du voile
dans les sorties scolaires c'est
vraiment prendre pour moi le sujet par
le mauvais bout aujourd'hui on doit
travailler sur qu'est ce qui nourrit le
communautarisme dans la société
je le dis là qu'il apprenons le prenons
la question par le bon bout
comment traite on nous la question du
communautarisme dans notre société
le voile est la conséquence du
communautarisme il traduit en fait des
réalités différentes certaines femmes ne
subisse d'autres choisissent d'autres le
font parce pour des raisons religieuses
d'autres le choisissent pour des raisons
politiques
donc ne mettons pas tout le monde dans
le même panier et traitons la question
de la place des du communautarisme dans
nos dans notre société qui est un vrai
enjeu pour la façon dont j'envisage mans
la république française qui est une
police d'une république d'intégration
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
que c'est ennuyeux tout de même que la
porte parole du parti aille à l'encontre
de la république en marche aille à
l'encontre de la position du
gouvernement qui ne souhaite pas
légiférer cet aprem interne c'est à
lablachère nava république en marche
laisse il avant le président du groupe
parlementaire voir comment il gère les
différentes sensibilités au sein du
groupe parlementaire
la position du gouvernement aujourd'hui
elle est simple elle est de lutter
contre la radicalisation et voir comment
nous pouvons travailler sur le
communautarisme qui est sincèrement là
je sais mon avis personnel un problème
par rapport à la vision jet de l'état
français une question d'ailleurs de diva
mariah sur le figaro madame busin
reconnaît qu ils y apprennent le
communautarisme en france qu'il faut
traiter
alors pourquoi ne pas interdire le voile
islamique dans l'espace public parce
qu'on va pénaliser que je pense à madame
à la mère du soldat qui a été tué par
ratifier
n la voilà c'est une femme absolument
remarquable qui va dans tous les lycées
les colleurs joie elle porte le voile
c'est ça culturelle et religieuse
elle porte le voile je n'ai pas envie de
stigmatiser quelqu'un qui prône la
laïcité qui fait un travail remarquable
de pédagogie sur justement le la
radicalisation et donc on voit bien
qu'on met dans le même panier des gens
dont sept sont des convictions
religieuses comme saddam d'eau qui
viennent de pays dont c'est la culture
que c'est difficile quand on sait
habiller toute sa vie dans un pays et
que tout d'un coup ni migrent dans un
autre pays où vous demander d'enlever
votre voilà on me demanderait
aujourd'hui si j me grey en inde de
m'habiller en sarre et je ne sais pas si
c'est une bonne bonne foi par et son nom
elle va faire le buzz donc je ne la
prends pas ce que je vais dire c est qu
on voit bien qu'il ya des gens dont
c'est la culture il ya des gens pour qui
c'est vraiment un souhait religieux et
d'autres pour lequel c'est un acte
politique
notre problème c'est l'islam politique
oui on va parler maintenant d'un
d'autres sujets c'est lubrizol près d'un
mois après la catastrophe de roi et
l'explosion de l'usiné chimique brigitte
oui effectivement il ya les auditions
qui vont commencer dans le cadre de la
commission denquête au sénat vous avez
dit juste après laffaire que la ville
était clairement polluée il y à des taux
d'oxygène très importants qui ont été
relevées est ce qu'au bout d'un mois
effectivement comme les et francis on
peut dire qu'aujourd'hui l'air que
respirent les rouennais est totalement
sain alors d'abord il n'y a pas eu de
taux de dioxine très élevé 1 qui voter
iso non ils ont été il était plus
important que la normale
dans l'environnement de rouen mais en
dessous des seuils de toxicité donc on
est vraiment toujours dans des dons taux
de diem si les rois d'aujourd'hui
alors qu'aujourd'hui les rouennais
inspire un air sain il le respire
d'ailleurs depuis le deuxième jour en
tous les cas dès que nous avons fait des
mesures il n'y avait pas dans le nuage
et ensuite dans l'air ambiant le trace
d'hydrocarbure d'amiante puisque nous
avons recherché l'amiante de traces de
dioxine est donc aujourd'hui les
rouennais peuvent être tranquilliser sur
l'air qu'ils respirent évidemment il ya
eu des analyses biologiques anormal chez
les pompiers qui sont intervenus sur
place dès bilan hépatique perturbé ça ça
ne va pas rassurer les rouennais oui
sauf que
un médecin pourrait vous dire que nous
ne savons pas aujourd'hui si les
pompiers qui alors pour pour les
pompiers
d'abord ils ont été en contact avec des
produits chimiques en proximité
notamment des hydrocarbures donc déjà
ils ne représentent pas du tout ce qu'a
subi la population générale qui était à
distance de lusine avait porté plainte
ensuite j ai cure et ensuite il faut
voir quels ont été les protections de
ces pompiers
est-ce que ils ont d'autres raisons
d'avoir un bilan hépatique perturbé on
pourrait imaginer que certains prennent
des médicaments
n'étant pas leur médecin et n'ayant pas
eu accès à leur dossier médical
il m'est impossible évidemment
aujourd'hui de dire s'il ya un lien
entre ce bilan hépatique perturbé et les
produits auxquels ils ont été confrontés
mais judy sanitaire à ce que l'état
prendra à sa charge la totalité de ce
préjudice
c'est à l'usiné lubrizol c'est aux
pollueurs de prendre en charge
évidemment les conséquences qu'elles
soient sanitaires environnementales
enregistré d'ailleurs le patron de l'ubs
rien
moi je les rencontre est effectivement
le premier jour lors de la visite de
l'usiné et je crois que elisabeth bornes
la revue après pour leurs demandes pour
demander à l'industriel de s'engager sur
un fonds d'indemnisation et c'est
évidemment aux pollueurs de payer seul à
dire on va papa
moment sur ce fonds à ma connaissance il
s'est engagé sur un fond mais je ne sais
pas s'il s'est engagé sur un montant de
toutes façons judo la justice passera
compris le préjudice sanitaire j'ai
voulu dire y compris c'est que les gens
se baladent toutes les conséquences
aujourd'hui
la justice dira qu'elle a sa
responsabilité mais si sa responsabilité
est engagée c'est à lui de alors un
prénom je ne suis pas juge donc je dis
simplement qu'aujourd'hui l'état se
retournera vers celui qui est en
responsabilité et mon travail c'est de
faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de
retard pour les prélèvements qui sont
faits dans l'environnement que l'on
sache exactement ce à quoi les gens
étaient exposés s'il y a une
surveillance sanitaire de la population
à mettre en oeuvre
je la mettrais sans attendre évidemment
qui est justement ce nouvel argent d qui
va contrôler chiffrer le préjudice qui
va recenser les victimes polluer
notamment par les suit vous le dites
c'est l'état qui va prendre cela en
charge
alors aujourd'hui l'état l'état ne se
préoccupe pas de qui va payer
enfin l'état moi moi même ministre de la
santé je me préoccupe de l'état de santé
des rouennais donc j'ai demandé une
évaluation des risques sanitaires par
les agences sanitaires en fonction des
prélèvements qui ont été faits des
résultats et ses agences me diront s'il
faut faire un suivi particulier de la
population rennaise
s'il faut un suivi particulier on mettra
en place les études nécessaires et après
on se retournera vers les responsables
évidemment de l'accident si cette
responsabilité est engagée et le juge le
dira vous êtes à la tête d'un très gros
ministères les solidarités et la santé
et il ya un débat qui vient à
l'assemblée nationale à partir de demain
c'est le budget de la sécurité sociale
alors ça pose beaucoup de questions
parce que ce budget va être en déficit a
effectivement à votre budget elle devait
être à l'équilibré pour cette année
c'est ce qu'on nous dise l année
dernière finalement il ya un trou de
plus de 5 milliards c'est notamment dû
aux mesures qui sont liées aux
mouvements des gilet jaune c'était une
mesure d'urgence sur la csg ou encore
l'exonération des heures sup normalement
ces mesures là elles sont compensées par
le budget de l'état
alors pourquoi pas cette fois ci parce
que l'année dernière nous avons voté en
tous les cas les députés et sénateurs
ont voté dans le plfss
la non compensation d'un certain nombre
d'exonérations la non compensation par
l'état vers le budget de la sécurité
sociale donc c'était pour simplifier les
relations état sécurité sociale qui sont
complexes avec des tuyaux qu'il passe
dans tous les sens donc l'idée était un
peu de simplifier les deux champs de
chant financier budgétaire et donc nous
avons fait voter
cette simplification dans plfss 2010 9
qui s'apprend de sécurité sociale je te
vois là et donc ils s'appliquent
désormais sur ce projet de loi de
finances de 2020 et donc nous le mettons
en oeuvre
simplement il ne faut pas se masquer la
face les mesures d'urgence économiques
et sociales et la dégradation de la
conjoncture économique ont abouti à ce
que l' équilibre ne soit pas atteint en
2020 mais probablement en 2023 et donc
nos rangs nous nous n'allons pas
renoncer un certain nombre de mesures
politiques et de choix qui ont été faits
dans le plfss de nouvelles protections
sociales pour maintenir cet engagement
de l'équilibré en 2020 le déficit pour
la paix sociale le déficit pour
continuer à faire les mesures qui sont
attendues par les français c'est pas la
peine c'est pas la peine sociale là nous
faisons des mesures vraiment de
protection qui adressent des nouveaux
risques
je pense notamment recouvrement des
pensions alimentaires pour les familles
monoparentales
je pense au pérou j'ai projeté tout ça
la conséquence de tout ça le déficit
finalement au gilet jaune dont je ne
fais pas porter le déficit au gilet
jaune
je prend simplement acte que nous avons
décidé d'un certain nombre de mesures en
faveur du pouvoir d'achat
elles ont des conséquences sur le budget
de la sécurité sociale et donc nous nous
avons nous nous arrangeons pour que le
retour à l'équilibré soit maintenue soit
dans les présidents processus et pas à
cause et gilet jaune
non c'est pas à cause et si les jaunes
c'est à cause de la conjoncture
je rappelle quand même que la
conjoncture économique de toute façon
nous aurait amenés
un budget en déséquilibre en déficit
donc j'irai que les mesures gilet jaune
entre guillemets selva mesure de pouvoir
d'achat augmenter ce déficit mais nous
n'aurions pas atteint l'équilibré de
toutes les façons cet acte fait débat
dans votre majorité
l'hôpital est dans une situation de
crise on est à six mois de grève des
urgences vous avez débloqué 750 millions
d'euros
ça ne suffit pas en tout cas est bien
pour le personnel de l'hôpital est ce
que vous allez en faire plus et qu'est
ce que vous allez pouvoir falloir et 750
millions d'euros sont uniquement pour
gérer la crise des urgences
ce ne sont pas des mesures généraliste
sur l'hôpital ce sont vraiment des
mesures qui servent à désengorger les
urgences à la fois en amont avec le
service d'accès aux soins qui permettra
aux personnes de mieux s'orienter de ne
pas arriver aux urgences quand elle ne
trouve pas un médecin et en aval pour
trouver des lits éventuellement réouvrir
délit avoir du personnel qui gère mieux
les lits hospitaliers et donc les 750
millions s'adresse aux 550 services
d'urgence sera pas de rallonge
alors après l'hôpital effectivement
souffre une crise qui est ancien d'une
dégradation qui est issu de je dirais
3,3 grand moment historique dans la vie
de l'hôpital il ya eu la réforme des 35
heures qui a beaucoup d équipes iraient
l'hôpital parce qu'on n'a pas recruter
plus de personnel au moment des 35
heures il ya eu la réforme de la
tarification hospitalière en 2004 qui a
vraiment changé l'état d'esprit de
l'hôpital qui en a fait une entreprise
et qui a fait câble qui a entraîné une
perte de sens pour les soignants de ce
qu'il faisait au quotidien il ya eu la
loi hpst qui est une réforme de
gouvernance hospitalière ces trois lois
ont abouti à une forme de désespérance
dion et des tarifs dont je termine et
les tarifs sont en baisse en fait depuis
dix ans depuis 10 ans ou créer
artificiellement un déficit nos vies
mais on ne rallonge pas et donc depuis
dix ans on a créé un déficit dans les
hôpitaux une dette hospitalière qui est
importante parce qu'on a réduit les
budgets hospitaliers on a réduit les
tarifs et llodra longeant 750 le termine
et dont il est question est donc enfin
d'autres questions l'année dernière
l'année dernière j'ai pour la première
fois depuis dix ans fait des tarifs
hospitaliers en haut c'est à dire que le
budget des hôpitaux a augmenté
je m'engage cette année deux nouveaux à
avoir des tarifs au minimum équivalent à
ceux de cette année c'est à dire soit
stable soit au je suis en train de
travailler à la campagne tarifaire et
enfin je prends un autre engagement qui
est celui de travailler sur la
valorisation des professionnels parce
qu'il y a un
aujourd'hui un des fondamentaux du
solaire il ya un défaut d'attractivité
on a du mal à fidéliser les personnels
je pense aux aides soignantes je pense
aux infirmières je travaille à une
valorisation des métiers notamment des
métiers y aura dans sera long non je
vous réponds pas par oui ou par non je
travaille je travaille à je travaille à
l'investissement dans l'hôpital comment
faire en sorte que le la qualité de vie
au travail des personnels soient
améliorées et je travaille une
revalorisation des métiers notamment les
métiers de plus en tension alors c'est
vrai qu' il manque 400 inférieur par
exemple à l'ap-hp des hôpitaux de paris
900 lits sur 20000 sont fermés à cause
tout cela de salaires trop faibles vous
venez de le dire aussi lié à ce problème
là est ce que vous allez augmenter la
prime de 100 euros qui a été donnée ou
pas eu de demande et 300 euros
et est ce que au delà il peut y avoir
une revalorisation du point dans la
fonction hospitalière alors sur le
quinquennat
aujourd'hui l'assistance publique
souffre d'un défaut d'attractivité
particulier à paris du fait du prix de
la vie à paris donc on va travailler sur
des mesures qui rendent les métiers en
tension à l'hôpital public notamment à
l'ap-hp plus attractif nous avons un
impératif c'est aussi de fidéliser les
personnels parce qu'il ya un taux de
fuite apportant les géants turnover très
important qui aboutit effectivement à
des fermetures de lits dont aujourd'hui
c'est sa l'engagement que je prends
c'est là dessus que je travaille c'est à
dire sur une valorisation des métiers
notamment il un début de carrière avant
pâques
a paris il ya un problème particulier
donc nous travaillons aussi mais pour
tout le monde il ya aussi des
difficultés de logement très très
clairement donc les personnels font des
très longs trajets pour venir travailler
donc il faut aussi qu'on travaille avec
la ville de paris notamment sur
l'accessibilité aux logements sociaux
nous
vous travaillez à certains endroits mais
sur la valeur du point
ça n'est pas comme ça que nous pouvons
travailler parce que la fonction
publique hospitalière aujourd'hui c'est
un million deux cent mille personnes
tous les métiers ne sont pas en tension
et donc nous devons valoriser les murs
général badauds générale des salaires
mais par contre des vrais des vrais
travaux d'attractivité et de je rappelle
quand même que nous venons de mettre en
place une prime de 100 euros pour tous
les personnels qui travaillent aux
urgences ou d'anciens euros donc 100
euros par mois
oui mais seulement 300 euros oui enfin
c'est 20 % d'augmentation de salaire je
sais pas dans quelles entreprises ont
fait des bonds de 20% d'augmentation de
salaire c'est donc là 100 euros c'est
déjà une forte augmentation
elle a été mise en place en juillet
c'est tous les mois c'est pérenne et
j'ai dit que j'augmente est par une
prime supplémentaire une prime de
coopération de 80 euros par mois pour
les infirmières qui s'engagent dans
notamment des protocoles comme des
futurs ou la prescription de radio donc
on voit bien que nous avons des outils
pour rendre plus attractives ces métiers
nous allons d utiliser maintenant vers
ans donc sur le budget de la sécurité
sociale et la république en marche et
quand elles marchent et rapporteur vous
demande un geste face à la situation
d'urgence de l'hôpital qu'est ce que ça
peut être ce geste est ce que vous
pouvez l'écouter proposer un geste face
à cette situation
donc je travaille évidemment sur la
situation des hôpitaux je ne suis pas je
suis pas dans le déni
d'ailleurs la loi santé ma santé 2022
visait justement à protéger l'hôpital
c'est vrai que j'ai fait un projet de
loi qui est une réforme systémique du
système de santé pour décharger
l'hôpital public de tout un tas de
contraintes aujourd'hui et l'objectif de
la loi c'était justement de mieux
structurer la vie de médecine de ville
pour qu'elle puisse mieux prendre en
charge les patients en ambulatoire faire
en sorte que tout le monde n'aboutissent
pas l'hôpital mais force est de
constater que si personne ne remet en
cause le cap de la loi et de ma santé
2022 beaucoup remettent en cause le
calendrier qui est trop longue
avec les dents le mans terre absolument
suite je voudrais que conviennent à ce
sujet précis c'est le problème des
urgences pédiatriques oui
les urgences pédiatriques sont au bord
d'une crise sanitaire ce style alerte de
28 chefs de service en ile de france une
dizaine d'hôpitaux en grande couronne
pourrait manquer d'un terne
qu'est ce que vous proposez comme
solution et en plus tous a manifestement
c'est dû à une erreur administrative
est-ce que vous allez demander des
explications et des sanctions ou alors
je suis assez agacé effectivement de
cette situation que j'ai découvert on
sait pas vraiment administrative en fait
c'est sont les enseignants qui
répartissent les postes d'internés
notamment les enseignants médecine
générale à paris qui se sont trompés
dans les chiffres
c'est il entend bien trop dans le centre
de paris est passée dans la couronne
donc l'administration tient compte des
organisations proposé par les
enseignants et en fait n'a pas vu
l'erreur donc c'est vrai que
l'administration absolument bloquer
durablement d'explication j'ai demandé
si on pouvait revenir sur le choix des
internes
juridiquement c'est prendre un risque
énorme
on ne peut pas remettre en cause de soi
des internes donc le choix qu'a fait
l'agencé régionale de santé
c'est de donner une prime de 500 euros
par mois aux internes qui accepteraient
d'aller travailler dans la grande
couronne plutôt que dans un service dans
paris intra muros
aujourd'hui il ya déjà donc ça va coûter
de l'argent de réparer cette erreur oui
je peux vous dire que je suis
extrêmement en clair il y aura des
responsables il y aura des sanctions
en tout cas vous allez demander des
explications et demander des
explications parce que franchement nous
met dans l'embarras alors que les
urgences sont tellement difficulté alors
que la pédiatrie manque de
professionnels je trouve que vraiment ça
tombe particulièrement mal on se trouve
que ça n'est pas stricto sensu de la
responsabilité du ministère
non vous l'avez dit on va parler
maintenant du rapport elle conneries sur
les métiers du grand âge rapport attendu
la semaine prochaine brigitte bouyer
rapport attendu sur la revalorisation
des métiers du grand âge 830 mille
personnes qui aujourd'hui dont 17%
d'entre elles toucheraient moins que le
seuil de pauvreté il faudrait 200
millions d'euros en 2020 pour augmenter
cette grille de salaire qui peut payer
pour ça qui va payer
en fait vous le savez nous avons d'ores
et déjà dans le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2020 des mesures pour renforcer le ratio
le nombre de soignants dans les ehpad
nous avons dans le rapport de madame
aime comme ray demandé comment on
pouvait mieux valoriser les carrières
début de carrière et fin de carrière
parce que ce sont des métiers pénibles
et c'est très difficile de s'engager
pendant 40 ans sur des métiers du grand
âge et dans la partie valorisation nous
travaillons également à une valorisation
financière de ses métiers
alors je suis en train de je vais pas
faire les annonces tout de suite
j'attends également cette réflexion il
ya des pistes de réflexion dans ce sens
alors dans le sens du mieux
bompas du moins d'augmentation servat
compris voilà à blé nous avons
évidemment un long une longue route
devant nous parce que le vieillissement
de la population va être vraiment
prévenant dans les 15 20 ans qui
viennent nous avons à nous organiser
pour être en réponse à ces à ses besoins
pour la population française mais nous
avons aussi à mieux former les
professionnels qui s'engagent pour qu'il
se sente aussi valoriser leurs actions
small que oui myriam el khomri a parlé
un petit peu un des pistes de son
rapport la part de libéralisation des
quotas de formation gratuite de
développement de l'apprentissage à ce
que pour vous ça ce sont de bonnes
pistes pour régler ce problème
donc moi jle pas encore le rapport je
vois que un certain nombre de pistes ont
été évidemment dévoilé évidemment ce
sont des bonnes pistes
évidemment ce sont des bonnes pistes et
donc que je reprends je vais prendre le
rapport de mme hamel comme riche quand
elle me le remettre à la semaine
prochaine et nous allons travailler avec
elle sur la calendrier de mesures
évidemment pour accompagner ces métiers
du grand âge
c'est un très beau défi dalsa de
domicile gisèle à domicile les aides
soignantes en ehpad
il y a énormément de métier on va avoir
besoin de ces métiers ce sont des
métiers non délocalisables ce sont des
métiers exprimant paupérisée aujourd'hui
ce sont souvent des femmes
parfois des familles monoparentales très
précaire on les a vus sur les
ronds-points et on ne peut pas continuer
comme cela ce sont des très beaux
métiers
merci tu introduis merci brigitte
boucher et à la semaine prochaine
évidemment sur audition publique
on va maintenant poursuivre le débat et
rendez-vous agnès buzyn parce que vous
avez parlé notamment de l'hôpital 2022
par exemple et ça ça intéresse beaucoup
les parlementaires qui vont nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau et les
parlementaires qui nous rejoignent c'est
bernard jomier sénateur apparenté ps et
à ses côtés julien ouvert députés aient
l'air les républicains de vaucluse
on commence par bernard jomier à les
premières questions
la pma vous lire revenir sur la pma
alors pas exactement sur la pma mais
sans les lois de bioéthique voilà
viennent d'être votés et dans ses lois
de bioéthique
il ya un certain nombre de sujets qui à
mon sens on était un peu rejetés ou
évacuées à l'assemblée nationale jean
prendre un qui est très concret une
femme à qui on implante un embryon
aujourd'hui si cet embryon et mal
formées qu'il a une trisomie par exemple
elle devra commencer sa grossesse et
elle fera une interruption de grossesse
or on peut on sait faire un diagnostic
en amont ça s'appelle le diagnostic
préimplantatoire le dpi est à ce stade
la diagnostiquer l'anomalie et ne pas
implanter un embryon gravement mal
formés à une femme
des députés ont proposé des amendements
en ce sens il ya eu un débat et vous
vous êtes opposés très fermement à
l'adoption de ces techniques dans un
débat qui a été très très dur je trouve
et qui à mon sens n'a pas beaucoup pris
en compte l'intérêt des femmes et le
respect de nos principes éthiques
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ces sites un
peu de temps monsieur juillet ce débat
parce qu'il est vraiment fondamental que
vous posez la question qui pour moi la
question qui était la plus difficile à
résoudre dans la loi de bioéthique bien
plus compliquée que la pma qui est
vraiment la question du diagnostic
préimplantatoire
et pourquoi ça a fait l'objet d'un débat
c'est parce que
on met en balance l'intérêt individuel
des femmes et des familles qui se
retrouve effectivement dans une démarche
de de procréation médicalement assistée
qui vont avoir des embryons implantés
qui vont peut-être se retrouver avec un
embryon porteur d'une trisomie et devoir
faire une interruption volontaire de
grossesse mais ça n'est pas du tout
pareil de réfléchir à l'intérêt
individuel et de réfléchir un intérêt
société un intérêt collectif et donc si
on se pose la question du point de vue
de la société française on se retrouve à
dire qu'on serait d'accord pour ne pas
implanter d'enfants trisomiques ça veut
dire déjà que par rapport à la démarche
société inclusive que nous avons on
considère que la trisomie pays européens
le fonds oui d'après les lois de
bioéthique justement à la française font
que tout ce qui est faisable n'est pas
autorisée c'est ce qui fait la grande
différence entre la france et les autres
pays qui n'ont pas de lois de bioéthique
dans plein de pays ce qui est faisable
est autorisé dans notre pays c'est aussi
de mode gothique c'est une loi de termes
de choses permise
et c'est aussi noix d'interdits on aura
ce débat aussi là vous avez rappelé
absolument tout cas le principe les bois
bioéthique française julie aubert un
autre sujet parce que c'est aussi dans
dans l'air du temps et c'était dans les
débats ces derniers temps l'aide
médicale d'état
la fameuse aide médicale d'état de même
buzyn qu'est-ce qui passe de 75 millions
d'euros à un milliard d'euros en moins
d'un milliard d'euros en quinze ans
l'aide médicale d'état
et jusqu'ici il y avait si vous voulez
un discours consiste à dire non on ne
peut pas revenir dessus nous on ne peut
pas mettre un forfait non on ne peut pas
la limiter il ya eu un article très
intéressant qui est sorti il ya quatre
jours dans le figaro qui parle c'est un
médecin de grenoble qui se souvient
annie migrants provenant d'afrique
centrale venu en france par
l'intermédiaire d'une association pour
faire soigner son sida et
son hospitalisation a coûté plus de
300000 euros parce qu'il ya un problème
il est ressorti aveugles et handicapés
et il a fait un procès à l'hôpital il
obtenu une indemnisation de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'euros par la
solidarité nationale
quand vous voyez des exemples comme ceux
ci comment est ce que vous pouvez pas
réagir en vous disant finalement cette
big aldeta elle est dévoyée c'est
exactement ce que j'ai dit monsieur
robert je trouve qu'on prend la question
de l'aide médicale d'état par le mauvais
bout on dit l'aide médicale d'état
augmente trop c'est une boîte noire est
donc comme ça augmente trop que ça
concerne des étrangers sans papiers
on va faire du rabot on va empêcher les
gens d'accéder aux soins en fait quand
on creuse le sujet on s'aperçoit que
l'aide médicale d'état est dévoyée
celles existantes de fraude
et c'est là dessus que je veux
travailler il ya énormément de gens
aujourd'hui qui rentre dans notre pays
non pas en clandestin ce ne sont pas des
immigrés de la porte de la chapelle qui
ont besoin de soins et vivent dans la
rue ils ont la tuberculose il faut pas
réduire des soins pour ces gens là mais
il ya énormément de gens qui rentrent
par des filières avec un visa de
tourisme et il ont l'aide médicale
d'état au bout de trois mois ils se font
soigner une petite gratuit sion eh bien
c'est ce que je suis en train de
regarder ce n'est pas une petite
proportion est en réalité quand on sait
pas ce que c'est mon stress est pas la
moitié aujourd'hui j'ai gardé un rapport
à l'inciter à aller gacé ali g f sur
l'aide médicale d'état je suis en train
de regarder quelles sont les
consommations de soins le premier le
premier poste de consommation ce sont
quand même les antibiotiques les
anti-infectieux donc c'est quand même
essentiellement des gens qui ont des
maladies infectieuses
cela ce sont souvent les migrants
doivent évoluer le rapport il ya deux
autres non non pas du tout j'adore vous
le disiez qu'il fallait pas toucher je
ne touche pas je ne toucha au principe
que quand on est un étranger sans
papiers dans notre pays qu'on arrive
quelles que soient goût qu'on habite
dans la rue et qu'on est en difficulté
il faut et tous les médecins et monsieur
juillet médecins comme moi je pense que
c'est principal chez les médecins
il faut pouvoir offrir des soins et je
ne vois pas un médecin qui refuseraient
de soigner quelqu'un qui n'a pas très
bien aujourd'hui le problème c'est le
dévoiement si tu formes de fraude
et là dessus je me suis en
j'ai à travailler parce qu'effectivement
il ya des filières mais c'est pas parce
qu'il ya des filières et des fraudeurs
qu'il faut empêcher ceux qui y ont droit
d'être soigné convenablement
c'est cet équilibre là qu'il faut que
j'ai bien sûr de ma santé 2020 nous et
heureusement d'ailleurs vous avez eu
cette dernière phrase laquelle je
souscris totalement sert tout système à
des fraudeurs et ça ne remet pas en
cause un système
il ya beaucoup de non recours aux soins
pour ce que les étrangers
hellemmes sur ma santé de fraude dans
certains secteurs dans l'autre oui dans
le domaine fiscal en particulier
lorsqu'ils pour ce qui est de ma santé
effectivement ça nous ramène à ce qu'est
la situation de l'hôpital aujourd'hui
qui est ça n'est pas la énième crise de
l'hôpital
cette fois ci un véritable affaissement
et vous vous le savez vous avait
présenté des éléments de diagnostic dans
la séquence précédente
plusieurs centaines de lits fermés à
paris des territoires ou des activités
de soins sont arrêtés parce que les
professionnels de santé s'en vont
maintenant de l'hôpital public et ça
c'est extrêmement grave vous avez
présenté un ensemble de dispositifs qui
sont des dispositifs destinés à répondre
à telle ou telle demande une prime par
si on essaie de faire l'organisation
parle est ce que vous pensez
est ce que vous croyez que ces
dispositifs sont réellement de nature à
répondre à la situation actuelle de
l'affaissement de l'hôpital dans notre
pays
est ce que vous pensez sincèrement que
c'est que ces deux niveaux
ce dont je suis convaincu c'est que ma
santé 2022
tu as vraiment la restructuration
globale du système de santé qui vise à
organiser complètement la médecine
libérale cette réalisation très
systémique elle est absolument
indispensable et c'est ce qui sauve rôle
c'est ça d'ailleurs dans dix ans dans 20
ans non non c'est pas dans dix ans dans
les deux trois ans qui viennent il y
aura déjà des transformations via tout
l'exercice collectif de la médecine avec
des délégations de tâches ou d'autres
professions de santé vont pouvoir
prendre en charge un certain nombre de
patients chroniques et que tout ne soit
pas que tous les malades ne soient pas
suivies uniquement par les médecins
parce que nous savons que beaucoup de
patients peuvent bénéficier d'un
environnement avec d'autres
professionnels de santé mais pour
l'hôpital pour l'hôpital vous avez
raison ça n'est pas une ligne
créer c'est ses 30 ans en fête ses 30
ans généraux à ce stade c'est à dire
mettre tout le monde autour de la table
est pas con que contenir le débat au
ministère au parlement à se voir toutes
les conférences conférence des
directeurs généraux des hôpitaux
conférence des présidents des
communautés médicales d'établissement
donc je vois les syndicats je suis en
train de quinze jours qui viennent de
faire cette concertation je fais
remonter évidemment leur vision leur
diagnostic pour être certain qu'on
partage aujourd'hui les pistes de
réflexion je ne suis pas sûr qu'avec
simplement réhaussement des salaires et
du point de salaire on sera compétitif
par rapport à certains d'accord là
dessus il ya une perte de sens
il ya des gens qui ont travaillé sur
cette tarification activités que
j'essaie de réduire au maximum pour
aller vers plus de qualité
il y a le renforcement de l'attractivité
des carrières ça passe pas par une
revalorisation d'un prêt il ya aussi le
problème du sous-financement de
l'investissement l'investissement du
quotidien et de l'équipement médical
s'est interrogé sur les hôpitaux et
autorités
oui moi j'ai un petit hôpital de
produits de proximité en plein coeur de
la circonscription pendant six ans n'a
fait la technique de la grenouille vous
savez quand vous voulez tuer une
grenouille faisait monter la température
tous les ans et ils ont fini par enfin
gouvernements de droite comme de gauche
d'ailleurs on finit par avoir la peau de
la maternité de l'hôpital et la rs a dit
à cet hôpital j'en ai dit j'ai pas ça
j'en serais je le sentais ne vous
inquiétez pas nous allons compenser ceux
ci avec en doublant la ligne d'urgence
et puis un an et demi plus tard on a dû
finalement pour des raisons budgétaires
on va vous enlevez cette deuxième idée
évidemment tous les élus sont montés au
créneau
l'agencé régionale de santé a dit on
aura finalement on va pas on va
peut-être pas au revoir ce aussi à côté
de ça j'ai une démographie médicale qui
est totalement déclinante quand j'ai
écrit à l'agencé irna sans médecin c'est
un désert médical on m'a dit on m'a cité
la définition du petit larousse
on se moque hors de moi pour me dire
qu'est ce que t'es un désert est ce que
vous ne pensez pas qu'il y a un problème
un moment donné
la manière dont on voit ces hôpitaux
parce que s'il s'agit de les transformer
en hôpitaux potemkine et qu'à la fin ce
soit quelques lits et vaguement une
activité sanitaire de façade
jeudi on y va tout droit moi je crois
qu'il est inadmissible un territoire
rural d'avoir un médecin urgentiste pour
40000 habitants dans un rayon de 30 km
je voulais avoir votre opinion pour
savoir comment est ce que vous pouvez
agir pour changer la relation que nous
avons je suis un élu national avec ces
agences régionales de santé
on ne les connaît pas et on a
l'impression parfois qu'elles font
soucis en dépit du bon sens uniquement
sur une machine comptable alors j'ai
demandé aux agences régionales de santé
d'abord de changer de posture d'être en
cas d'un accompagnement des élus et plus
justement dans une posture de régulateur
comme elle l'avait lorsqu'elles ont été
créés il ya une dizaine d'années donc on
est vraiment dans l'accompagnement des
territoires aujourd'hui parce
qu'effectivement les déserts médicaux
sont insupportables pour tourner mais je
voudrais partager une contrainte
aujourd'hui la démographie médicale est
très très très dekra t et donc nous
manquons de médecins dans les
territoires en médecine libérale nous on
compte médecin à l'hôpital
nous manquons de médecins en médecine du
travail dont en comble mais ça c'est un
problème mondial aujourd'hui
non mais aujourd'hui la démographie
n'encourage les médecins quelque part à
faire des remplacements parce qu'on les
encourage pas c'est une honte c'est une
rouge aujourd'hui c'est ce que j'appelle
brutalement le suis complètement c'est
ce qu'ont à l'intérim cannibale aurait
dit je suis en train je me suis engagé
lors du pacte pour la refondation d
urgence à organiser un intérim public
justement pour éviter que ces
intérimaires privé qui se font payer un
prix d'or en fait grève le budget des
hôpitaux
aujourd'hui quand on ferme une maternité
ce n'est jamais pour des questions
budgétaires
j'ai dit aux agrès ce que je ne voulais
plus parler de budget quand il s'agit de
la ruralité ont la crise du gilet jaune
la montre et on a besoin de renforcer la
présence territoriale
le fait est que pour faire tourner une
maternité il faut 8 obstétriciens 8
anesthésistes lui infirmier de bloc 8
pédiatre parce que c'est ça pour faire
tourner une maternité 24 heures nous ne
les avons pas aujourd'hui quand on ferme
malheureusement un service c'est juste
parce que nous n'avons plus les
professionnels donc nous avons besoin de
réorganiser le territoire emporte sont
toujours la proximité des hôpitaux de
proximité seront
le point d'entrer dans le système de
questions précises parce que j'ai été
interpellé sur twitter par un
téléspectateur tout à l'heure concernant
ce serait une première en france
la fermeture la réorganisation d'un
hôpital à longué-jumelles c'est entre
saumur et angers un hôpital qui était
actuellement reçoit un service d pas
d'un service de soins et de réadaptation
qui pourrait être racheté par un groupe
privé vous donnerez vous le feu vert ou
pas j'ai demandé une note à mes services
parce qu'effectivement j'ai entendu dire
qu'un hôpital public serait rachetée par
le secteur privé
ça n'est pas mon souhait aujourd'hui oui
en tant que médecin du service public
hospitalier fait toute ma carrière
l'hôpital public je n'ai pas dans l'idée
qu'on va vendre les hôpitaux publics au
privé il ya un secteur privé on en a
besoin il fait à mon travail il ya un
secteur public qui répond à d'autres
besoins il je soutiens cet égard de la
santé
à ce stade je n'ai pas encore donné je
n'ai fait aucune signature je vais
regarder
en tous les cas si c'est un cas ce sera
peut-être un cas isolé mais voilà on a
besoin des deux pour danser la santé si
le public n'est pas en mesure d'apporter
la santé ou concitoyens pourquoi vous
êtes là la réalité c'est que tous les
professeurs de santis l'hôpital public
qui partent dans le privé lui il
s'évapore pas et donc le secteur privé
se porte bien et lui à gauche mais il a
les capacités d'engager absolu en
solitaire parce que vous savez ce que
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une aussi une
politique qui est de laisser l'hôpital
public ce lanvin peut partir ce fantasme
là c'est la réalité énorme et c'est la
rouille a dit franchement ça fait 30 ans
que l'hôpital effectivement a subi des
réformes voit ses tarifs baisser
effectivement mais moi je suis venu dans
ce ministère j'ai quitté l'hôpital
public
trois jours avant d'être ministre
j'étais encore en consultation à
l'hôpital public trois jours avant
d'être ministre et mon objectif c'est de
remonter l'hôpital public il rend un
service évidemment nécessaire d'abord
dans la formation
et puis ils accueillent république ne
peut pas accueillir le secteur privé des
publics avec des problèmes sociaux des
problèmes extrêmement complexe on a
besoin des deux secteurs ils ne jouent
pas le même
et donc ils sont complémentaires à
celles autre question de bernard jomier
julien robert vouliez évoqué aussi la
laïcité aux établissements oui
hospitalier parce qu'ils se posent dans
les écoles mais tout à l'heure vous avez
dit vous étiez pas misé l'éducation
nationale l'information était remontée
jusqu'à moi mais vous êtes en charge les
hôpitaux et se pose effectivement la
question est bien de des auscultations
où certaines femmes ne souhaitent pas
être examinée par des hommes la question
aussi parfois de fête religieuse qui
rentre dans l'hôpital et donc la
question aussi qu'ils se posent
notamment dans les zones urbaines et
bien c'est qu'est ce que l'on doit faire
par rapport à ceux ci comment établir
une limite stricte sur la laïcité sur
les questions de laïcité pour éviter une
forme de communautarisme qui se
développerait insidieusement à l'hôpital
alors à l'hôpital c'est différent des
sorties scolaires
on est dans le service public donc la
neutralité du service public s'impose
donc il n'y a pas de signes
ostentatoires religieux au sein de
l'hôpital public des solutions de soi
puisque julie aubert de pointer du doigt
ses des femmes ça se règle en général et
des règlements à l'amiable
souvent elles n'ont pas le choix en
réalité donc parce que quand le médecin
est un homme il est un homme
donc je n'ai pas de remonter aujourd'hui
pas dire qu'il y en ait pas mais je n'ai
pas de remontée de problèmes très
prévenant dans les hôpitaux de
communautarisme j'ai demandé qu'on me
fasse un point régulier chez les plats
situation chez les personnes âgées
personnes
après il ya la diffuse de certains de
certains aliments c'est le jeune le
jeûne rituel ses études ils sont des
demandes de circoncision rituelle
remboursés par la sécurité sociale
c'est pas forcément la question du voile
parce que le voile vous l'avez très bien
d'aller dans cette négociation
et c'est aussi les enjeux ne soient pas
des passions je pense je suis garante du
service public hospitalier aujourd'hui
service public hospitalier et neutre et
je n'ai pas de remontée de difficultés
particulières chez les personnels mais
chez les percées comportement comment
les équipes géré ça c'est aujourd'hui
des équipes arrivent à trouver des
solutions
ça passe par des explications par de la
pédagogie
elle trouve des solutions à l'amiable et
là encore je n'ai pas de remontée de
difficultés particulières avec les
patients
déjeuner aujourd'hui j'ai demandé aux
agences régionales de santé d'interroger
les établissements de santé pour me
faire remonter des cas particulier parce
que je n'ai pas à trancher sur des cas
particuliers il ne me revient pas récusé
qu'il n'y a pas de remonter que ce soit
de la part des personnels ou pour ce qui
concerne les patients oui par exemple on
pourrait me dire que une famille a été
violente parce que la femme ne voulait
pas être par exemple examiner par un ça
doit arriver peut-être j'ai des
remontées de ce type mais pas vous savez
je reçois un nombre de courriers
considérable
je reçois 7000 courrier parents d'élus
et je n'ai aucun courrier qui concerne
la laïcité dans ce qui me remonte
aujourd'hui au ministère je ne dis pas
qu'il y en a pas mais en tous les cas ça
ne va pas être un phénomène massif mais
je crois pas qu'il faille y mettre ce
débat toutes les sauces en fait vous
parler d'alimentation le fait qu'on
puisse manger casher ou sans porc à
l'hôpital ça existe depuis des années
des années
le vrai sujet de l'hôpital à l'heure
actuelle c'est que dans les territoires
ruraux et dans les territoires urbains
dans tous les territoires les gens
maintenant ont du mal à accéder à
l'hôpital les urgences sont dans l'état
qu'on connaît et donc la véritable
question qui se pose dans notre pays
c'est comment ce système de santé peut
continuer sur des bases de solidarité et
d'ailleurs au delà le système médico
social puisqu'on voit les ehpad la crise
des ehpad qui est aussi lié juste un
point vous avez dit qu'on manque de
médecins en même temps on n'a jamais eu
autant de médecins dans notre pays on
n'a jamais eu autant de médecins dans
notre pays donc ils sont bien quelques
parents malgré tout les médecins et les
autres des zones sans niang mais le
ratio reste un ratio ratio qui est un
ratio qui est humaine tout à fait
satisfait
le problème c'est que il ya d'une perte
de sens pour un certain nombre de
soignants s'il faut bien le dire
il s'interroge sur ce que sont les
missions de l'hôpital et je crois que si
on ne règle pas la question des missions
des organisations et des financements en
même temps on n'en sortira pas et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut mener des véritables
états généraux de l'hôpital moi je je
pensais qu'en 2017 quand emmanuel macron
été élu qu'il travaillera une loi
hôpital parce qu'il y avait une
nécessité parce que l'hôpital n'allait
pas bien
on n'a pas eu de loi hôpital et je crois
que c'est même plus le temps d'une
l'hôpital où
je pense que il faut mettre tout le
monde autour de la table dans des vastes
ces états généraux pour poser en dire
ensemble quelques ce qu'on attend de
l'hôpital dans notre pays et qu'est ce
qu'on lui donne comme moyen ma santé
2022 concerne aussi l'hôpital
quand on organise quand on dit dans ma
santé 2022 qu'on organise la gradation
des soins c'est bien pour protéger les
hôpitaux du grand jubilé c'est sa vie
c'est ça le processus est beaucoup trop
long et aujourd'hui on vous savez bien
qu'on a approuvé que j'ai approuvé les
principes de ma santé 2022
donc les le débat n'est pas là c'est pas
mal sorteux généraux ça mettra beaucoup
trop tard aujourd'hui de concerter donc
je suis en train de faire mes parents
est sur les dents qu'est ce qu'il vous
dira tout le monde en même temps de
quelque part en voyant ce diagnostic non
mais le diagnostic idée en fait il est
totalement partagé tout le monde sait
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut faire pour
l'hôpital j'ai pris moins de 12 ans non
il faut réduire la t2a elle a vendu les
gens fous alors éclaté la tarification à
l'activité qui fait qu'il faut faire de
plus en plus d'actes quelles que soient
leurs indications quelle que soit leur
qualité
simplement pour que l'hôpital soit
rentable ça n'est pas comme ça qu'il
pouvait se réduire il faut le supprimer
on peut probablement pas tout supprimer
on peut parvenir au budget global ça
fonctionnait pas bien non plus donc faut
qu'on trouve un équilibre
moi je veux une tarification qui
tiennent en compte qui te prendre
prennent en compte la qualité la
pertinence des actes et ça je suis en
train de le renforcer
on va être multiplié par 5 le
financement à la qualité en espace de
trois ans ça va atteindre un milliard
d'euros dans le plfss 2021 donc on est
bien sûr un renforcement d'une
tarification qui redonne du temps aux
soignants et qui soit capable de
financer ce temps pour que ce soit pas
cette course à d'activité on a besoin de
rendre attractif des carrières on a
besoin de réinvestir dans des abysses
innovants à ses investissements courants
dans l'hôpital c'est à dire par exemple
mais par exemple celle de paris de
radiographie les appareils de radio
d'aidé mais parfois de parfois
simplement les brancards qui sont cassés
ça les gens fous il ya vraiment
aujourd'hui un des dysfonctionnements
permanent à l'hôpital qui font que les
gens sont épuisés et qu'il quitte
l'hôpital public
moi je veux leur donner envie de
travailler pour l'hôpital public en
général quand ils choisissent l'hôpital
public c'est parce qu'ils veulent donner
un sens à leur vie
donc on va on va être à julien aubert
qui est ici a écrit emmanuel le faux
pauvres prophète c'est un brûlot allez
je dire comme ça non contre emmanuel
macron ce que cache la révolution macro
et il dit alors je vais vous paraphraser
vous allez dire que vous êtes d'accord
vous dites que le gouvernement gouverne
beaucoup avec les symboles par exemple
l'égalité hommes-femmes au lieu de
s'intéresser à des projets de fond comme
justement la santé qu'est ce que vous
lui répondez quand il écrit ça moi je
travaille à des projets très pratique
très pragmatique moi je suis dans le
quotidien des gens dont la mesure
concrète
je suis pas dans les symboles du tout
vous m'entendrez pas faire un discours
philosophique pas ma formation chez une
femme de terrain
je sais ce qui dysfonctionne et je suis
là pour réparer donc mais attention ne
soit pas bornée oui vous savez je
travaille beaucoup monsieur 00 vouloir
concertée parce que des rapports on en a
beaucoup vous dit le diagnostic est
connu sur le piton moi je suis pas
d'accord c'est vous savez les états
généraux
je crois qu'on est déjà au stade de la
révolution les états généraux sont déjà
derrière nous à force de trop vouloir
concerter et de vouloir faire des
rapports on en oublie que le politique
guettait dans l'action je crois
véritablement que si vous êtes convaincu
que c'est la t2a qui pose problème alors
allez-y et vous trouverez l'opposition
allez c'est à dire supprimer la scène
mais oui elle passera de 60 à 50%
non voilà il n'est pas question de la
supprimer et qu'elles ont une baisse oui
d'accord mais vous seriez point crucial
non parce que le met d'ailleurs là tout
à l'heure massa a parlé d' hpst et la
couverture santé hôpital c'était la loi
hôpital patients santé et territoires de
roselyne bachelot qui a modifié
profondément la gouvernance vers les
directeurs d'hôpitaux et là je pense
qu'il ya aussi un vrai travail
il faut rééquilibrer ses dires de
témoins pouvant plus de pouvoirs aux
directeurs d'hôpitaux demande de faire
en sorte que les choix médicaux soient
notamment sur les personnes arrêtées en
soit mieux entendue en tous les cas que
le binôme président de la communauté
médicale et directeur d'hôpital qui a
les cordons de la bourse que ce binôme
fonctionne mieux soit plus équilibrée
parce qu'aujourd'hui dans la perte de
sens dans le faible engagement des
professionnels de santé
il est aussi chez les médecins le fait
de ne pas avoir du tout les les leviers
pour recruter pour organiser leurs
services comme il le savant de laisser
partir nos invités parlementaire je vais
vous poser une question concernant le
projet sur les aidants ces personnes qui
vous nous qui vont aider des proches ou
des parents qui sont malades ou
gravement malade pour l'instant il ya un
projet qui prévoit de financer 100 jours
sur l'ensemble de leur carrière
est ce que ça peut être plus papa à ce
stade c'est déjà un énorme budget qu'on
va mettre sur un sujet qui est connu de
longue date qui est la place des aidants
dans notre société on considère qu'il ya
environ 10 millions de personnes qui
aident au quotidien proche les conduit
hier c'est aujourd'hui non aujourd'hui
ce congé existe c'est un congé sans
solde c'est un congé de trois mois sans
solde que peut prendre n'importe qui
dans son entreprise et nous créons une
indemnisation sur ce congé sans solde et
son gendre toute la vie sociale
à ce stade c'est déjà un investissement
et qui permettra aux gens de trouver des
solutions
et évidemment
je comprend d'autres voudraient des
congés plus long ça n'est pas rien merci
julien aubert merci bernard jomier elle
est revenue sur ce plateau d'auditions
publiques qui on va accueillir
maintenant yves thréard qui va nous
rejoindre
[Musique]
le regard distrait art bonsoir bonsoir
forcé position publique des ministres
alors vous avez la santé chevillée au
corps ça se voit vous vivez votre sujet
vous êtes dépensière aussi j'ai remarqué
parce que bon le système de santé
français était peut-être un peu malade
et il est vous l'avez détaillé depuis
une trentaine d'années et tout le monde
le sait alors vous allez remettre de
l'argent pour les urgentistes remettre
de l'argent pour les personnes qui
s'occupent des personnes âgées
d'ailleurs aussi pour la pédiatrie aussi
des urgences vous allez dépenser de
l'argent aussi pour la qualité pour
améliorer la qualité des soins vous
l'avez vous l'avez dit on voit vous avez
un travail que vous maîtrisez mais que
vous ne voulez pas partagé dans des
états généraux parce que peut-être que
vous vous dites que le diagnostic est
fait il faut maintenant aller dans
l'urgence là où vous êtes beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins à l'aise j'ai trouvé
c'était notamment sur le problème de la
laïcité on prend le problème du mauvais
bout alors ça veut tout dire ça veut
dire que vous n'êtes pas tout à fait sur
la ligne de monsieur blanc caire je
pense qui a trouvé que le voile n'était
pas souhaitable de notre société
à ce moment là je voudrais vous poser
une question
il ya des élus hier qui ont écrit une
tribune dans le journal du dimanche pour
dire qu'il voulait constituer un pôle de
gauche à l'intérieur de la majorité qui
s'organiserait autour de jean yves le
drian
le ministre des affaires étrangères vous
pourriez appartenir à ce groupe d'avoir
sont des élus ne suis pas élu j'ai
jamais joué aux cartes
non je lui plais ce qui pourrait
constituer
je trouve ça bien que chacun revendique
un peu sa sensibilité en fait je pense
que je suis profondément en même temps
je suis profondément responsable par
exemple sur la terre on peut être
responsable responsable sur le budget de
la sécurité sociale en responsabilité de
maintenir l'équipe je suis pas
dépensière uniquement des pensées a par
contre je pense qu'il ya des vrais
nouveaux besoins sociétaux
on parle d aidant on parle du grand âge
et là je veux faire des réformes en
profondeur pour répondre à ces nouveaux
besoins de protection sociale or mais je
fais en même temps
une protection qui est énorme c'est
celle des retraites petites questions
sur les personnes en difficulté à la fin
de leur vie est ce que on créera une
cinquième branche de la sécurité sociale
c'est soit tableau pas ça non je ne suis
pas je pense que ça ne sera pas un
nouveau risque en tant que je crois
c'est très difficile de faire la part
entre ce qui est purement de la
dépendance et ce qui est de la maladie
un stade avancé
ok parce qu'il n'y a pas de raison
qu'elles fassent aussi aura pas de
cinquième d'accord alors en revanche les
retraites alors jean paul delevoye est
arrivé au grand jour avec un poste de
haut commissaire mais il vous a pas un
peu de tirer le tapis sous les pieds
c'est pas c'est lui qui gère ce dossier
complètement maintenant à 100%
il a toujours géré ouais il a toujours
géré l'aja perd on a des réunions
hebdomadaires ont fait le point des
concertations qu'il est en train de
mener
c'était déjà le cas depuis 18 mois donc
c'est un sujet qui lui a été entièrement
confiée à une équipe dédiée
il ne fait que ça il a travaillé dans
l'ombre c'est là un peu protégés pendant
18 mois
maintenant il est un peu exposées
directement du ministre maintenant
non enfin en général je fais partir pas
toujours
il arrive que je ne puisse pas par
exemple aller à rodez où je ne sais plus
où a lieu le débat avec le ministre à
lens le saunier parce qu'en réalité j'ai
un agenda parlementaire et ça veut dire
qu'une marée était basse sur les routes
bien sûr je ferai à développer avec lui
et vous êtes sur la même longueur d'onde
en est sur la même longueur d'onde
c'est à dire sur aucune honte parce
qu'on comprend plus rien si c'est très
simple schéma side et un schéma cible
c'est le schéma qu'a proposé jean paul
delevoye qui est un bon schéma de
redistribution et plus équitable
notamment c'est à dire comme vous le
dites oui simplement quand on est
compliqué à atteindre quand on voit
justement voilà ce que quand on écoute
on se dit qu'aujourd'hui 42 régime qu'on
veut rassembler dans un régime universel
pour qu'il y ait davantage d'égalité
très bien mais on se dit qu'il va
falloir dépenser de l'argent pour faire
des compensations aux régimes qui
pourrais tu es bien un peu lésé donc ça
ça va coûter cher
on se dit que ça va prendre beaucoup de
temps parce qu'on parle d'un objectif
on se dit que une usine à gaz qui
existent aujourd'hui va être remplacée
par une usine à gaz
moralité que ça pourrait être tellement
plus efficace et que ça va coûter plus
cher alors il est évident raviver un
programme le contraire oui je veux
convaincre du contraire il est évident
donc quand on a un régime autonome ou un
gel spécial qui est très éloigné du
régime cible on ne peut pas demander aux
professions aux professionnels de
changer complètement de couverture
retraite alors que une forme
d'engagement de l'état vis-à-vis d'un
régime auquel ils ont cotisé donc des
exceptions dont seront des exceptions
n'ont donc il faut une période de
transition très longue pour aboutir au
régime si pour certains régimes dépenses
de l'avs et pour certains il va falloir
les accompagner financièrement parce
qu'en fait mon t shirt histoire il ya
clairement des professions qu'on a sous
payés en sachant très bien pour
rattraper ce sous investissement dans
des salaires par une meilleure retraite
et donc si on change ce contrat moral
entre guillemets et que l'art est la
retraite redevient liées aux salaires il
faut remonter des salaires donc cet
engagement de transformation de modèles
ça va prendre du temps et il est en
attente on attend aujourd'hui c'est en
concertation et branche par branche et
c'est probable aussi que ces délais
soient très différents d'une profession
à l'eau et pourquoi je voudrais
convaincre monsieur thréard c'est quand
même à l'arrivée on sera vers un système
plus juste que je pourrais avoir 2043 en
fait
mais le vétéran tout ça oui on sera vers
un régime plus parce que je pourrai
promulguer
non vous de ce sera dans quelques années
les nouveaux entrants ça concernera que
les nouveaux entrants
donc tout ça est en concertation l'idée
c'est que la période de transition vont
dépendre d'un régime à l'autre en
fonction de leur éloignement de régime
cible plus leur taux de cotisation est
faible par rapport au taux de cette
cotisation prévue
plus le taux de rendement est élevé plus
en fonction de différents critères on
voit bien qu'il ya un
chemin pour aboutir au système cible
avec parfois un accompagnement qui peut
concerner l'assiette de cotisation qui
peut concerner une revalorisation des
salaires donc enchères pour chaque
profession
le chemin est différent le temps peut
être différent mais à l'arrivée c'est un
système beaucoup plus juste qu'un livre
à l'arrivée à la trois petites questions
un l'âge pivot on n'en parle plus je le
serai les concertations se faire puisque
ça ça fait partie du bouquet s'est parlé
oui là je lâche en tous les cas ce qui
est clair c'est qu'il ya un âge deck
libres 1 h des clips du système existant
dont je dirais que l'âge légal de 72 ans
n'a plus tellement de valeur c'est comme
les 35 ans l'âge légal
ça c'est un engagement du président de
la république il persiste et un âge à
partir duquel on peut faire valoir
nouveaux entrants vous avez pas répondu
est ce que ça ne concernera que les
nouveaux entrants aujourd'hui on est sur
des transitions longue
est-ce qu'on va jusqu'au stade de faire
cette réforme
uniquement pour les nouveaux entrants on
verra comment les concertations de se
passe mais aujourd'hui ne le faire que
pour les nouveaux entrants ça veut dire
qu'on conserve ses 42 régime plus le
régime universel tel un 43e pendant une
longue durée
ok c'est pas question crédible cette
question question importante selon tout
le monde se pose cette question est ce
que cette réforme sera votée avant la
fin du quinquennat
il reste deux ans et demi et avec toutes
les concertations qui ont lieu les
grèves annoncées les grèves annoncées
est-ce que vous pouvez nous assurer
comme le premier ministre l'a fait
d'ailleurs avant l'été que ça sera pour
l'été 2020 aujourd'hui nous sommes en
ordre de marche pour écrire la loi et
pour qu'elles soient votées avant 2020
après qu'est ce qu'on met dans la loi
est ce qu'on met un cadre général
est ce qu'on y met le système cible le
système complet mais est ce qu'on y met
les transitions pas peut-être qu'on peut
se laisser encore du temps de constance
alors il y aura encore une autre loi qui
précisera tout au deuxième quinquennat
s'il y en a aujourd'hui ça va dépendre
évidemment des discussions qui sont en
cours avec les partenaires sociaux
savoir qu'elle est
le contenu de la loi aujourd'hui nous
travaillons sur ce texte à partir du
système cible donc ça veut dire que ça
sera des grands principes qui sont posés
sur la table mais que dans le détail on
ne rentrera pas dans bien le régime des
avocats où le régime des centres précis
surtout je ne pense pas qu'on soit prêt
à décrire dans le détail les 42 c'est
très important ce que vous dites là je
aujourd'hui j'attends que les
concertations et lieu l'emploi mais
verront jusqu'à quel point nous pouvons
aller dans le détail des transitions
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas encore acté
merci yves mercier n'a avancé avec vous
et agnès buzyn merci d'être venu sur le
plateau d'auditions publiques lcp
assemblée nationale public sénat et le
figaro live n'oubliez pas que vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission sur
figaro live ainsi que sur les sites et
compte twitter de lcp public sénat
bonne semaine et à lundi prochain pour
un nouveau numéro d'auditions publiques
merci